you in five four three two one
welcome everybody to the world-famous h3
podcast so nice to be back here with
y'all hope you had a terrific week
today's episode is sponsored by clip
candid and stitch fix now fans of the
podcast know they saw a new video that
we announced the gender and name of our
baby and I got to do my gender prank on
everybody
friends of the podcast were not
surprised they were not surprised but
they also the idea I was expecting all
the comments to be like was waiting for
this from the podcast but I had a few
you did okay I think I guess good
everyone when they saw that video
they're like I know exactly what the
goof is here so we did it I did my
little prank I did the clear balloons
instead of white I thought that was more
slick because really you shouldn't
assign gender ela do you think that it's
child abuse to not assign them a gender
at birth
sort of as if you're like if you just
like dress them in white you're like you
she's like why do I have a why am i
different from all the kids I have a
penis and and you're like oh no just
ignore that you know yet you don't know
that don't say that how do you currently
some people do that it's probably very
few people though yeah that's pretty
extreme not very representative
yeah that's pretty extreme so here's a
boy I'm sorry to say to those of you
that think that's wrong with me to say
Theodore Yohanan Klein little teddy you
know it's funny there was a post on the
server that somebody predicted it yeah
like a hundred days ago they're like
Theodore that's Katie I don't I was
wondering if we mentioned it at some
point on the podcast but I don't think
so I don't think so cuz someone would
have pointed that out and then that post
or his guest was just when you guys
announced it yeah I mean if you
mentioned it at one point you definitely
didn't mention it when you initially
announced hmmm made me feel not you know
special yeah that predicts
well it was just one person so the guy's
a genius what can you do here walk home
we did have this name for like I don't
know maybe three years already
like we just kept saying if if we have a
boy that name is perfect yeah although I
started to get cold feet about the name
because we're watching the Ted Bundy
files and when these tapes
yeah the Ted Bundy that's a creep but
then I was like man I know a lot of
weirdos named Ted yeah and I don't
necessarily Cruz exactly Ted Cruz I mean
the guy walks around with like white
schmutz from this he had like a y'all
remember the Ted Cruz yeah yes in ski to
Ted Kaczynski that's what I was saying
that's a Unabomber I knew that the
Unabomber Dan yeah yeah yeah so a think
I got the K last yeah so there's a lot
of weird heads and I started feeling
like I don't know that I want my child
to be a Ted because I want him to be a
Theodore and I want him to be a Teddy
but you know when he gets older he's
just gonna go by Ted and Ted means
serial killers exactly so he may be the
Unabomber our child but until then good
Teddy Roosevelt
that's the one we started right he's
named after Teddy Roosevelt Oh got it
yeah but he was probably just did you
know it always works out where you spite
your well you can't overthink it right
it's like yeah well the thing is even if
he grows up to be a serial killer or
like a domestic terrorist he'll be cute
so like till he's like ten because once
they're ten look you don't have control
over their destiny so much so it's like
oh he's so cute and then when he turns
like 18 or 22 or whatever and we'll be
like what happened to Teddy he goes by
Ted now and he blew up what about Teddy
from westward that was a cool character
named Teddy yeah that was a cool the
cowboy right or not only Anson Edgerton
that's true I like Ted Danson that he
will not go by Ted I forbid it
I'm already turning into a stern dad no
Ted in this house
yeah yeah oh my friends are cool at
school call me Ted what I forbid you to
be called Ted yeah well anyway I'm very
excited about that
ela is looking so friggin pregnant you
guys wouldn't really because she is
crazy I forget she's pregnant because
she wears such loose clothes but you
can't even tell
like just stand up it's like oh she's
just she's into hockey looks like a
hockey jersey are you gonna pull it up I
don't know why on camera you can't tell
because well I gained 20 pounds
if you most women during their whole
pregnancy gained 20 pounds ILA's stacked
right now I sigh when I see her naked
recently because she her clothes drapes
oh well she hides it it's incredible I'm
just like whoa it's crazy I have the
same reaction through myself I get
scared of an instable showing your
stomach or no I'm not gonna press you I
just don't know I mean I pretty much
showed it just put a shirt on yeah but
ok don't show it I'm not I have enough
pressure in you yeah so I've showed it
all over Instagram alright that's true
I'm following the doctor's instructions
they said I should gain one pound a week
you know you started underway yeah so I
think you have more irritation to gain
weight than most people but I've been
feeding her I've been but what happens
after the birth you stay beautiful and
healthy you are underweight yeah you
look good I'm happy like I finally I'm
enjoying foot weight for the longest
time I I had no appetite yeah that was a
weird one yeah but I'm having fun
have you read one single comment for any
of these pregnancy videos or any video
we've made in the past three months
ela is radiant yet she is glowing she is
beautiful
who was this ogre next to
you're basically you read ethan is
glowing and oh i'm going when is ethan
do clean yeah comments like literally uh
basically that message saying exactly
that right now basically you are my
Fiona - and I'm your Shrek - your Fiona
essentially I don't know whose Puss in
Boots shredder better put some boots can
you believe there's a character in a
Disney Pixar movie called Puss in Boots
imagine that and also he was like a
seductress - he was like Don Don Juan
and his name was Puss in Boots I'm
telling you he [ __ ] like crazy that
cat so we got a ton of stuff my goodness
there's so much yeah to cover because we
were gone for a month and then we came
back and we had Vsauce and there's just
so many incredible stories we haven't
had the opportunity to talk about the
Gillette ad that everyone was pissed off
about Kevin Hart being outed from
hosting the Oscars because of some old
tweets
we've got Sandra Bullock's Kevin Spacey
Kevin yeah Kevin Spacey of course who
who released what must be the most
bizarre video ever aired in the hew
totality of human history yeah it's just
I mean where else and then we've got
Sandra Bullock on Ellen talking about
her beauty product that they inject and
I am not kidding you I have video
evidence that I'll present to you they
inject baby foreskin into their face to
keep their skin healthy and glowing this
is what rich people do with their money
they literally baby foreskin it's
incredible I got all that and so so so
much more dog the bounty this dough I
want to explain this okay
so this is a Teddy fresher he just came
out today and this is an interesting
story this isn't really a promotion
as much as it is I want to show you guys
so we're starting this limited-edition
we're illud that makes hand-drawn art
and we printed like high really high
quality print on shirts and we make a
super small amount of them and once it's
sold it's done mm-hmm so on this first
collaboration look who we got to model
the shirt dawg the freaking bounty
hunter modeling the dog the bounty
hunter shirt
it all started I just made that drawing
just for that fun I wasn't it wasn't
even gonna be a t-shirt I was just
making a drawing at the time and I
always found his look I got crazy and
interesting so I wanted to draw him for
a while
and then we were like oh we should put
that on a shirt mm-hmm and then they
contacted us yeah and that was awesome
well we were trying to get ahold of dog
through like our agency and whatever my
mom my mom she always does this she goes
oh this was one of her classic moves
growing up oh one of my clients is does
this and then the information she
revised is like so from another planet
wrong like she goes what her famous one
was uh she goes Japanese people are
taller than Chinese people because they
get more Sun and they grew up were like
what they grow like plants like the more
Sun the taller they get and she's like
she's like yeah that's what my client
told me my mom cut hair so it was just a
running gag enough she said one of my
friends does his licensing or something
like that lion probably tried to you
know them and they're like we have never
we don't know it she's like yeah I work
with dog I work with dog I'll put you in
touch and then we contacted her like we
we have never worked with dog don't
email us that wasn't right like our
production manager wrote up this really
professional email we kept following up
with them cuz we're like we really want
duck we sent them in five follow-up
emails and finally like we
we leave us alone well why do you think
this it's so funny
but once we posted the picture then his
daughter reached out to us and then a
beautiful magical thing happened his
daughter
actually happened to be a fan which is
so amazing yeah shut up to Bonnie yeah
so what a thrill what a joy I loved it
it was great working with them and it's
just so freakin cool
I love this photo I mean I want to frame
this and put this up we have to just so
cool there's a vapenation one too he did
do we have that one Dan uh I don't have
it on standby but I can grab it real
quick it's worth seeing
well oh yeah I wanted to talk about the
Super Bowl two before we got into it
what's the deal with the Super Bowl it's
the most-watched televised event in the
United States more than football it is
football or more than baseball yes
it's one yeah it's bigger yeah dad do
you guys have stats on the how many
people watch the Super Bowl first how
many people watch the World Series
I don't yeah I'll pull it up yeah and we
watched a game of football really it
blows the World Series away though
interest way bigger so much for the
American pastime yeah the football well
the Super Bowl became the strange
phenomenon where even people that don't
care about football ended up watching it
for the commercials imagine that because
it's where I've seen commercials from
the Super Bowl right in 2018 a hundred
and five million people watch this
that's a third of the country yeah
that's in three nuts one also people who
have Super Bowl parties so you're
probably looking at two-thirds of the
country that's but somehow these
marketing geniuses figure this out where
these companies spend I think this year
I read it was like five million dollars
for one spot during the Super Bowl and
they they like make the craziest
commercial they possibly can and so it
turns into this whole spectacle of
of commercials and so everybody's like
oh I just want to watch the commercials
and there's even like YouTube
compilations of Super Bowl commercials
and everybody's watching these
commercials I remember I think in school
they showed us some of the commercials
from the Super Bowl what to learn from
them yeah because they were like good
you know design or good whatever stuff
like that dances five million dollars
for a 30-second ad spot Wow
I remember when I was a kid was 1
million and that was like insane five
million yeah you want a bagel Hedy fresh
for a how could you make back five
million even I guess that's a hundred
million people watching yeah yeah that
level of exposure you can't get that
almost anywhere but I feel like we would
not make that money back I'm Terry fresh
well it's be a good way to go just make
a farewell commercial farewell from
Teddy fresh we went bankrupt making this
commercial I feel like people would
check out the product but then they'd be
like I'm not interested yeah I don't
care about the Super Bowl though is my
point I feel like I
I wish I cared about the Super Bowl it
seems like everyone's having fun they're
eating dip you know whoa go rares that
seems fun but I can't do it the Raiders
have not been in the Super Bowl
well long time that's who's in it though
right no the Rams oh the Rams yeah I
don't even know apparently la is in it
right then that's right yeah LA Rams so
there you have it the LA Rams
incidentally I do know that hitting with
the helmet is illegal and Rams hit with
the helmet so I'm not sure what that
says about the team yo I think that's a
loss for the Rams but I think I've been
thinking about this a lot and I've been
doing this I've been doing therapy I
think that everything sports related
I hate because my dad likes sports and I
think subconsciously growing up here
that is having a Super Bowl party of
course I guess who's not gone I'd rather
be anywhere else honestly I think
subconsciously in an effort to be unlike
my dad
I pushed away all sports to a neurotic
degree because when my dad would be in
there watching sports I would be playing
EverQuest for 15 hours there you go and
so I think my I think I've been thinking
a lot about this stuff you know
therapy's weird
you don't really analyze yourself you
learn a lot about yourself but an effort
to not spend time with my dad I avoided
all sports related activity that is
interesting and I still to this day I
just can't do it I want to I see my
friends enjoying sports they watch
basketball Lakers Kobe whatever you know
layup from Shaq I don't know I can't get
into it you know do you ever play sports
growing up at all no I [ __ ] they
tried to make me they tried to make me
Dan soccer
first they tried to make me play soccer
well soccer sucks so well guess what I
sucked at it it was embarrassing okay
then I refuse to go then they tried to
make me play t-ball dan yes baseball the
American pastime let me tell you about
t-ball
I hated it and one time I went up to bat
I graduated from t-ball and then I went
to the real baseball and the first pitch
some kid is trying to be a superstar he
throws the ball and he begs me in the
stomach and I lost my breath I doubled
over and it was the only time I ever got
on base was when some dude threw a ball
at me the only time I ever got dad yes
Dan it was sad it was the only time I
got on base and let me tell you this
they're like oh you get four space and I
was like oh I'm so [ __ ] up next player
up hits the ball Dan listen to this hits
the ball line drive between first and
second I'm running the second base the
ball hits me in the foot oh man [ __ ] my
foot up and then I'm out because the
ball touched me
so that's my highlight of my baseball
career
it's tragic dude [ __ ] sports EverQuest
for life but I feel like um I feel like
people who get in the sports and play
sports day you had you have to need a
lot of support from your parents you
need to like do the sports with somebody
mm-hmm but my dad was busy watching
sports and not playing sports with me
sorry I'm not a superstar dad hope I'm
enough for you to love me still so
here's dog doing vacation everyone's
like wow Ethan's really damaged
I actually just recalled that first
baseball I got on base one time from
being hit immediately after that I got
hit by a ball on my way to second base
do you understand how messed up that is
so I've got beamed in the stomach hit on
the foot
I'm out I never did anything all I did
was mess up what a nightmare
here's dog doing the babe mesh it was a
beautiful thing I just thought I didn't
know I had so much fun lock I was gonna
tell my therapist maybe I was gonna take
Monday off but maybe I need a double
session all right let's move on
we got the Jillette ad let's start here
shall we so this Jillette ad caused a
lot of hubbub during the break Jillette
made a commercial about toxic
masculinity now first of all message of
the commercial Asajj should we watch it
first yeah so it's called we believe the
best men can be Jillette a short film
first of all first of all any time you
refer to anything as a short film you're
obnoxious yeah it's a commercial yeah a
short film by Gillette Brothers in
Cannes is a [ __ ] you're trying to
sell razors yeah idiots but how about a
trawls
yes it's not not at the Cannes Film
Festival a short film by Gillette watch
us at Ross though 28 million views so
that's a lot here's the the description
says bowling harassment is this the best
a man can get it's only challenging
ourselves to do more that we can get
closer to our best to say the right
thing to act the right way we are taking
action at the best men can be org join
us now I guess what so another facet of
the stories that Gillette used to have
this slogan it was a the best a man can
get right then yeah it was it was
something like that so I feel like
they're responding to themselves because
they think they used to be problematic
like a guy shaving and doing a close
shave and being like the best man can
get yeah that's right and then a girl
would like kiss him on the cheek but it
was old school every yeah that was weird
and yeah you're catering to a bunch of
dudes using razors yeah we want kisses
on the cheek look at some old school
coffee commercials were like the wife
make the coffee and it's all about the
guy I seen 50 I seen coffee commercial
1950s where the cut wife makes a bad cup
of coffee and the husband throws in our
face and burns her gives the third
degree burns permanently it's like whoa
they're like get Folgers next time [ __ ]
I was like whoa the 50s were crazy but
it's true you gotta get your coffee
right woman I mean at the time those
woman just stayed at home they didn't
work so it's like the least you could do
is get the coffee right
so anyway let's watch bullying couple
broken there's the man can get there you
go
so that was their old commercial yeah I
love how to press those old guys look
like they just got a cancer diagnosis or
something they're like no I just saw the
new Gillette commercial and I realized
what a punk guy is it I pledge not to
pause this video it's been going on far
too long
raps a problem again laugh at all
[Applause]
[Music]
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same experiences
if you cry well I'm wondering if she had
a church the Shiva teardrop down her
face or is that like uh okay that would
be so dramatic making the same old
excuses but some kids are just having a
child and there will be no going back
because we we believe in the best in men
men need to hold other men accountable
smile sweetie cloth to say the right
thing
to act the right way some already are
may break in ways big who made this a
bunch of [ __ ] women made this much
feel small first of all and I'm sorry
deposit I pledged not to but I guarantee
the people that made this commercial
have beers that they use oils in they
don't even use razors you know what I'm
saying these guys these guys wear
scarves in the spring because the boy is
watching today
[Music]
tomorrow okay yeah
so my initial reaction was you sell
razors mine what are you talking about
it's just a commercial like are you
really gonna preach to me right now
you sell razors Europe trying to make
money it's well so the examples that
keep showing is like stuff that I've
never seen mm-hmm like what well honey
I've only ever heard like a 80 year old
man say that no thing that happens I
guess I don't roll with but and then
then the other assumption is like Oh
someone who's problematic is gonna watch
this and be like oh my god yeah oh my
god it's just it's pandering but they're
just going with the trend and trying to
benefit from it you know right cuz he
did it yeah Knepper Nick they just see
that they think this is what is going on
right now to be like a walk
woke company or whatever mm-hmm they
thought this is just gonna look good for
them but it's just so not well in your
ex parent it's just did that it doesn't
seem that genuine but like who are they
enduring to because they are a company
for men's products and they're saying to
men you're a problem so it's like a
weird thing of hating your own customer
it's very weird I don't know and it's
just a commercial right that is really
the bottom line you just sell razors
this isn't a short film by the way
either you obnoxious [ __ ]
you know that's it I'm throwing my
Gillette out and I'm and from now on I'm
gonna be nearing my [ __ ] [ __ ] to do
that by the way I had this whole thing
where I was gonna near my butthole but I
never happened I'm glad you know Mitch
down yeah I had a bunch of their
products and people you know that's that
you shoot people were like do not I was
getting really worried so I did
1.3 million downloads but I think
ultimately Dan you made a good point
about this ad didn't you well yeah I
mean my take on this is that you know
people should just ignore it because I
mean what they were looking to do is
stir the pot and get people angry and
all of the people in social media who
were pissed off and throwing out their
razors and everything there they're
playing right into their hands because
that it's almost an extension of the ad
in a way because all the people that you
know get outraged that get outraged
proof right yeah that there's a problem
so the picture of the yes so this genius
goodbye
Gillette hello dick yeah dude
already owns a razor mm-hmm you already
bought it
you'd you're the only one now you have
to go buy a new razor they already made
the money and also you know that you
can't flush that right he's gonna have
to put his hands into his own toilet and
take it out so dumb but yeah I mean like
people getting triggered by it and
posting stuff on social media like this
it's just further advertising for them
because you know the people that that
like the ad or you know like the message
of the ad or whatever like oh hell yeah
and they're and they're triggering these
people that makes it even better
well it's like when people have a
problem with Nike and then they burned
their shoes yeah right and Nike sales
went alike right but what it does is
continues the conversation and the
conversation is about Gillette and these
huge brands just all they want is people
saying
name right like the last time you ever
said Gillette the world but it's just
like all the sudden we remember Gillette
yeah you know and that commercial is so
awful they knew that people were gonna
get pissed yeah it's all very cynical
for me as a woman like that situation
that you described that when people will
say to you why aren't you smiling people
do say that happened and I've never seen
it happen so I got a girl well I don't
hang out with [ __ ] weird Creepo dudes
either yeah but even to me someone who's
been in that situation has been annoyed
by it this doesn't do anything to me
that's just you trying to appeal to who
and Reno fail yeah yeah fake that's
that's really it it's just so fake well
this guy he's gonna do suppose this guy
put a bag over his hand after taking
this photo and grabbed it out of the
toilet
oh he tried to make the glow garbage
pickup hook I just love this guy knowing
the heat once the photo was done he had
to grab it out of the toilet I bet you
this guy kept it too he washed it off
he's like I'm not gonna waste there's a
bunch of these yeah I think these guys
took the bait and I think you're right
about that here's this another genius
this Gillette razor
I was sent on my 18th birthday has been
with me through basic training four
deployments and seven moves I've used
almost every day for the past 15 years
great Coomer so for now yeah so
basically what he's saying is that this
isn't a tremendous product yeah but
because of an ideological difference I'm
I'm not gonna use anymore but the
product and I vouch for it is tremendous
this is better than the commercial
really
but since Gillette thinks I'm a bad
person I'm throwing it away
this guy's like listen this is the best
product I have ever owned in 15 years
yeah they should retweet this I'm like
holy [ __ ] and even just the statement
because Gillette thinks I'm
bad person like again you're just you're
playing into it cuz people gonna see
that and like great you know this guy
identifies with the negative behavior
depicted in this ad and is offended by
it so I like to let even more now yeah
people like if you're I mean if you're
that sensitive really though about it
I find that strange too exactly they
didn't say you're a bad person dude they
were talking about a very specific type
of dude people the people who got super
triggered by it were so sensitive and
defensive that it's weird everybody's
kind of this F this whole event was
stupid because I didn't find the
commercial that as a man I wasn't
offended I just felt pander to and that
the commercials and was disingenuous and
stupid yeah but I didn't feel that they
were calling me a bad person
yeah so I don't know what that means
about you but I just think then you're
way too defensive dude and also notice
that he didn't even put it in the trash
can this is a fake thing he's gonna say
I love this product way too much
he's kidding that thing for another 15
years he's definitely not throwing that
thing away
yeah that guy loves that razor more than
any life itself suppose razor God ever
made
interesting stuff what else we got here
yeah I found that uh sexist coffee ad
that you were talking oh yeah through
the discord the one where the guy
punched his wife in the face don't think
he punches her but he he dresses her
down papa
Eddie solves a crime I was kidding no
this coffee is criminal that finger in
the face
how petty might copy its murder
I'm I'm so accomplished what do I do I
need to ask a man this [ __ ] is so bad
yeah oh just young lady all you do is
add why are you dumb
you dumb idiot no cooking required
because coffee
sorry what is that accent dry forages
it's that weird transatlantic [ __ ]
they used to do back dreams it's
literally a fake funny like even in
Hebrew when you watch old stuff they had
like an accent like yeah that's what
dance talking about there was a weird
television accident yeah people put on
huh
very strange this is well they cold
coffee comes from comes from look at
this [ __ ] girl like please don't
punch me you know it's a crime he scares
her yeah you know what to cry she's like
what not to have delicious coffee
everyday like American Psycho I now suck
my dick under the table yeah that's
pretty crazy and that's a perfect family
yeah that's I want I'd like to see
Folgers making apology videos for their
commercials from the sixties boycott
folger can you imagine
Folgers is this the best we can do the
best part of waking up is a [ __ ] from
my wife Audrey can Folgers that's their
slogan best part of waking up case you
were confused dealer okay you knew okay
well with seconds commercial break I
haven't having a lot of fun here with
Gillette and everything next up let's
talk about let me be frank starring
Kevin Spacey's last role on this planet
Earth after this quick commercial break
so we will see you guys very
shortly if you watch this show then you
probably have awful oral hygiene and
your mouth probably stinks and that's
why I quip is such a beautiful sponsor
that I love because this toothbrush is
all you need to have a beautiful
kissable minty fresh mouth and let me
tell you about this toothbrush it has
the softest bristles in the game it is
not gonna harm your precious sensitive
gums that's number one
that's the secret number two it's
vibrating this packs the punch of a $200
vibrating toothbrush in this beautiful
slick little tube for only a fraction of
the cost but here's where the magic
begins it tells you it vibrates and it
pulsates when it tells you when to
switch quadrants to make sure you get
that perfect brush every time and you
don't lose track you're like oh oh it
brushed my mouth for 20 seconds I'm done
no two minutes
that's how long you need to brush and
that's how long this baby forces you to
brush to make sure that the teeth don't
fall out of your head by the time you
turn 30 quip has changed my life I do
not use any other toothbrush because let
me be frank the bristles are the softest
it tells me how long to brush and it
vibrates there's really nothing else you
need and it's delivered to your house
you don't flee go to the freaking
grocery store and mess around in that
section you never know what you're
getting trust me this is a toothbrush
the first and last the Omega and the
Alpha that you'll ever need toothbrush
wise that's quick so there's 1 million
people there happily using this product
quip starts at just $25 so go to get
quip dot-com slash h3 right now and you
get your first refill refill pack for
free check it out you're gonna love this
toothbrush go get it at GE tqu IP comm /
h3 I wish I had access to this product
when I was younger because I had braces
the old-fashioned way and that is so
miserable the same I'm so jealous of
people they get to use this beautiful
incredible product candid what they do
is they send you out a mold you take
them older your teeth and they send you
the super high-tech like braces molded
to your mouth specifically that is like
braces but you can take it out it when
you eat and basically you could take it
out when you brush
I got immense gums my mouth was a mess
for the years I had this
is the future it's a fraction of the
price and it brightens your teeth also I
have had stains on my from where the
braces were this is the future it's
cheaper it's better I am so jealous of
everyone that gets to use this
incredible product it takes six months
on average and cost on average 65% less
than braces everything is delivered to
your home you got a White Glove customer
service in addition an email and phone
support candid will set up a video call
with you to answer any questions you
have and walk you through the modeling
process and they only use orthodontist
unlike some other companies that do this
use dental professionals whatever that
means this is the real deal that's it
it's incredible they customized it
specifically for your teeth they've got
a network of orthodontists that review
your specific case and provide you with
a 3d preview of what your treatment will
look like and basically having real
orthodontist is the main reason you're
gonna love candid because because you
can't really replace a real orthodontist
with a dental professional you're one
step away from getting straighter whiter
teeth take advantage of candids risk
free bottle and kik guarantee plus when
you use my dedicated link candid code
comm / h3 you'll save 25% on your model
and kit that's candid koat.com / h or
you get 25% off the price of your
modeling kit candid code calm / h3 i am
so jealous please guys go fix your teeth
thank god for stitch fix because i never
have to go into another Macy's again as
long as I live and I cannot stand that
place another department sports stores
that you're expected to shop because
it's frickin it's it's hell on earth I'm
not gonna mince words
that's what stitch fix fixes it's a new
world and we need to shop for clothes in
a new way for men and women and kids
stitch fixes and online personal styling
service that finds and delivers clothes
shoes and accessories that fit your body
budget and lifestyle just go to stitch
fix com / h3 take a survey you tell them
your size what styles you like how much
you want to spend on each item and a
beautiful genius fashion guru goes to
work selecting perfect crunching the
numbers
calculating an algorithm and they're
like whoa this is the perfect look for
you and they send it to you right to
your freaking door you try them on and
you only pay for what you love if you
don't love it you return the rest it's
that easy
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free there's no subscription
required you can sign up to receive
scheduled shipments or just get your fix
whenever you want they've got a styling
fee of only 20 bucks but that's applied
towards anything you keep from your
shipment so get started now at stitch
fix comm slash h3 you'll get an extra
25% off when you keep all the items in
your box that's stitch fix comm slash h3
to get started today stitch fix comm
slash h3
welcome back everybody to the greatest
podcast ever made can I say that again I
can say it doesn't make it true but
don't say it you guys probably heard
about this everybody heard about this on
Christmas Eve Kevin Spacey who as being
tried for sexually assaulting a minor
not saying I'm not making a comment to
his guilt or whatever but he's being
charged disgraced fired from Netflix for
the scandals by the way house of cards
the last season was such dog [ __ ] oh god
it's just so much it was already bad and
now it's like so much worse well it's
all because like cuz before I could hate
watch it kind of yeah still kind of
enjoy it
well they had a the story arc was going
somewhere right and then all of a sudden
it was just like oh he's dead you know
yeah I guess they're doing what they can
with it but um be that as it may Kevin
Spacey puts this out on Christmas Eve
responding to his allegations of assault
and the character of Frank Underwood
okay
and he blurs the line between the
character and him he addresses things in
the show while addressing real-life
accusations and he on one hand says I
didn't do it but on the other hand he
also was like what does it matter if I
did it and he's very kind of like his
creepy character from the show which I
don't see how that helps his case not
all and he's like in a kitchen that
looks like might be his own kitchen it
has to be where else would he do it they
dudes at home he's like been outcast
from society so it's not a fad it's not
a set it's in his kitchen who recorded
it his wife and assistant yeah well that
one didn't know that I forgot a lot of
scrutiny because when he
accused he came out as gay right I was
like why did you do that so at any rate
very bizarre such a weird video and I do
wonder if people told his lawyers he was
gonna do this cuz usually when you're
involved in something like this the
lawyers like say nothing to nobody I
think without asking me first I think
you thought to himself that he knows
better than everyone around him like
this is gonna be the best thing for me
well you know me and Eli were we're
talking we're like if you're innocent
this isn't the video you make no this is
when I watched that video and made me
feel like is more guilty because if
you're innocent you're you trust the
system you trust your attorney I'm sure
he has very expensive very good you're
not gonna find any proof right so yeah
like what you don't do is go and try to
muddy the water and then be you're like
psychopathic character that you play and
try to tell everyone you didn't do it
while winking at the camera in the
psychopathic character because that
makes me feel like makes me feel like
what yeah also as I was like you know
you're did you know yeah you're fired
right cuz at one point he's like I'm
gonna show you guys the whole video in a
minute but he was like you didn't
actually see me die did you and I'm like
Frank you're not your dad
Oh anymore bigger this isn't Canada this
is just you and your kitchen right now
Netflix is out yeah you're you are dead
this is not canon but that being bad as
it as it may he is a phenomenal actor
and he delivers the lines very well the
writing is honestly very good the way he
blurs the line but I again it's a bad
choice bad because his is a good actor I
dislike creepy characters yeah it's not
a good time to
creepy exactly the time that's what
makes it so incredibly bizarre but the
lines were written brilliantly performed
brilliantly but was the taste brilliant
wasn't timing brilliant I don't think so
I was thinking to myself well this is
probably the last thing he'll ever act
and so you might as well be dissolving
took it took full creative control on
this one yeah
listen in my kitchen I I gotta tell you
I didn't really like how so we called it
in our house house of tards to be honest
because don't tell anyone because
everyone in that show is just so hard
they're just so tired I didn't say the
r-word it's house of TARDIS because
nothing makes sense in that show like
Frank is just killing people it's just
like I'm gonna throw off on the train I
don't want no cameras he's killing
people they're drugging people they're
doing all it's like oh and everyone's
just like oh what's going on it's just
it's like a you know what I think it is
a super high budget soap opera yeah I
kind of liked the first season as as
that as like it kind of like a guilty
pleasure I guess whatever bad to show
everybody you're kind of enjoy it but it
got worse no yeah well the last season
was just bad bad bad bad bad bad but
anyway let's watch this video I've hyped
it up enough here we go
with without further ado let me be frank
which again the title itself is
brilliant Frank other word let me be
frank know also it's like a plea like
let me be frank mm-hmm it's like a
triple entendre I mean that's pretty
brilliant that being said he definitely
did it it's not I don't know
clean camerawork bad lighting I know
what you want oh sure they may have
tried to separate us but what we have is
too strong is too powerful I mean after
all we shared everything you and I I
told you my deepest darkest secrets
I showed you exactly what people are
capable of I shocked you with my honesty
but mostly I challenged you and made you
think so again it's like who are you
being are you Kevin are you friends so
he's doing it in the I think he's
talking about his personal stuff when he
actually came out as gay right
mmm he's like I I shocked you in way
Yeah right everyone knew he was gay not
really shocked there's shocked us with
the timing yeah okay you look breaking
it down even though you knew you
shouldn't even know you knew you
shouldn't
so was he still talking about himself
anyone who says right he said you trust
me even though you knew you shouldn't oh
so okay so again who are we talking
about here
you know and besides I know what you
want you want him back of course some
you want me Bank believed everything and
I've just been waiting with bated breath
to him he confess it all they're just
dying to have me declare that everything
said is true and that I got what I
deserved
wouldn't that be easy it was all so
simple
only you and I both know it's never that
simple not in politics and nominal life
okay so he's clearly talking about his
accusations hmm but Frank now what we
know about Frank the character he would
lie through his teeth and if you heard
Frank saying this he definitely did it
Yeah right
like Frank always did the worst thing
possible and then lied to try to cover
it up so by him being frank and
addressing the allegations
it's him saying I definitely did it and
I'm trying to lie it confused you to
cover it up right
literally that's what it means that's
the vibe on getting anyway I mean that's
the interpretation what do you think I
don't know what did he think that it's
like creating just just more confusion
yeah he's kind of trying to muddy the
waters it's a PR thing I think but you
wouldn't believe the worst without
evidence would you you wouldn't rush to
judgments without facts would you did
you no not you
you're smarter than that anyway all this
presumption Mavis you know that girl you
would believe me I did not push that
girl in front of a subway and season one
you believe me don't you
I know what you want it's like we saw
you do it did i watch the show
I'm satisfying ending and to think it
could have been such a memorable
send-off I mean if you and I have
learned nothing else these past years
it's that in life and art nothing should
be off the table we weren't afraid not
of what we said not of what we did and
we're still not afraid because I can
promise you this if I didn't pay the
price for the things we both know I did
do I'm certainly not gonna pay the price
for the things I didn't do so what did
you do yeah what is he talking about him
oh of course they're gonna say I'm being
disrespectful not playing by the rules
like I ever played by anyone's rules
before I never did and you loved it
anyhow again he has a person before this
was extremely private he never confirmed
nor denied he was gay people didn't know
anything about his personal life as what
was known for so again he's blurring the
line so much that he's saying you loved
that I never played by the rules but
nobody so he's talking about Frank
because nobody knew anything about him
or this we loved you on the shows so
again it's like it's it's we it's not a
good look to blur between a psychopathic
murderer and yourself so much
and you like cutting stuff right it's
very yeah boys making Christmas dinner
presumably I wish you pointed out what
is up with the lighting yeah the
lighting warps dungeness yeah yeah bad
lighting guys and we need some I mean we
no no it has a really awful blue light
they need some more like white balance
up right scale that up despite all the
poppycock they had them up they got
headlines the impeachment without a
trial despite everything despite even my
own death
I feel surprisingly good and my
confidence grows each day that's soon
enough you will know the full truth wait
a minute now that I think of it you
never actually saw me die did you what's
with the ring dude you're done you're
out of the show they fired you still you
never saw me die then president of
Netflix is like I saw you die dude yeah
the ring was another Frank Underwood
thing
dude what's the significance of the rain
no I haven't seen the show in a long
time but it was I just googled it and
there's a bunch of pictures I guess he
would always like put the ring okay
after you did something evil okay
and then the final act of strange that
was the worst possible way to end that
video in the fact it's not that dramatic
hamster sound effects say it's close
yeah
because the tone was so serious and so
artistic and then that brought me right
out of it
golly he's like yeah I'm worth the I'm
worth the fifty million bucks but go
ahead and grab that audio jungle sound
bike he has a weird one man a bunch of
people in the chat saying he reminds him
a lot of those Garth Brooks videos oh
yeah the same like cadence what if the
ultimate twist was that Kevin Spacey was
just a Garth Brooks or so no there you
go yeah so again this was a really
terrific phenomenon Christmas Eve
absolutely incredible creep it just
makes me think that he's guilty why
would you even make this I tend to agree
because if it's a desperate attempt to
confuse because yeah and uh a small
correction from what you said before I
guess there there are allegations
against him for you know making advances
against minors but he's on the thing
he's on trial for the guy was 18 it was
still oh okay my bad
that is definitely my bad thanks for
correcting me on but there are always I
think it's about that you got him drunk
right and then yeah I think raped him so
hold on he was not underage during the
alleged this article is from December
this past December about the trial and
sexually assaulting an 18 year old is
okay thank you for correcting me yeah I
think I heard the saying that he can't
got him drunk got him really drunk I'm
good well there's another allegation
from the 80s of a 14 year old so yeah
yeah well you know what I don't pass I
don't make a conclusion I'm only on what
happened or whatever but just based on
the video alone I'm sure Netflix did
their own investigation too and they
decided to fire him yeah I would like to
think so but be that as it may the video
is very strange and just an assumption
is that I don't think an innocent person
would make that video I could be wrong
well you're right I mean his lawyer
thank you you heard of have an I'm right
his lawyers had to have had an aneurysm
when they saw this there's no way as
someone who's dealt way too much with
lawyers for my own taste the official
policy is always shut up so next up
we've got so many great stories are all
shocking Nita
by the way I've gone vegan I'm going
good speaking of PETA and I'm like
keeping up with it ten days in oh yeah
man yeah I'm definitely I've lost like
two pounds I think at least but I feel
nice you know it feels good I've had
absolutely relentless diarrhea though
since I like so so relentless dude oh my
god in gas I can confirm the gas
I've been hot boxing ela but they don't
tell you about that part I'm eating
everything I used to just no meat or
dairy but I guess as you pointed out
then that it can be shock to your system
because I don't think there's been a day
of my whole life that I've gone without
either dairy or meat yep there you go
that's a big change that's a big change
I turned to eastern side one night when
while we were sleeping
I turned to his side and then all of a
sudden I got gas in my face the middle
of the night
pocket Ida turn back you ever seen those
videos of like methane coming off from
like icy rivers that's what the that's
what like whoa that's a methane bubble
why ain't rate PETA has come out
basically I went vegan because of these
PETA commercials so I thought they'd be
interesting here so the first one they
tweeted out there's two this I thought
was as a joke this is apparently a real
thing they tweeted words matter and
their understanding of social justice
involves our language evolves with it
here's how to remove speciesism they
call it from your daily conversations
yes be she ism as if as if they
understand our language like just think
about what you're saying you idiots
literally literally they don't
understand your language who are you a
fan they can't be offended by what we
say so you are they make it seem like
it's about the animal but it's about you
the animals don't understand what we're
saying you're offended and so you want
us not to offend you and you're gonna
just have to stop using anti animal
language exactly what anyway let's start
from the top kill two birds with one
stone no say freed two birds with one
stone does that make sense but Bert why
would a bird want a scone most guns are
good yeah but I don't think it's very
bird scones this is poppy a disco in a
sweet bread but it's gone it's more like
a dry English I thought it was yeah feed
two birds with one scone do you
understand that most of these are like
Shakespearean sayings this is like part
of our heritage part of our English
language this is a part of our cultural
identity and you want to whitewash it
for this garbage feed two birds with one
scone imagine saying that to a strange
on the street they'd be like I'm sorry
what you know feed two birds with one
skunk
next they say be the guinea pig be the
test tube that's like you know they
really doing I was gonna say that
this is so stupid you know what they're
doing is like it reminds me of when they
started taking the n-word out of vogue
Huck Finn in particular which is this
wonderful timepiece written by Mark
Twain written back during slavery and
it's about the sweet boy that goes on
this epic journey with his slave his
family's slave and he uses the n-word
all the time because that was normal at
the time but this kid is deeply under a
sustained
for a person and it is a really a
landmark book and a real time piece and
so to chant rewrite the history why did
they change it to you know or they just
removed it I changed it to slave I think
they like that is so so it's a rewriting
of history yeah I mean it doesn't serve
anybody the kids are not racist people
reading our races but it's so important
to know the fact it's good to have this
stuff to look at is what the past used
to be like horse commercial that we saw
of the coffee of course it's so shocking
what are we gonna erase it like it never
happened and we should know that it
happened mm-hmm
be the guinea pig be the test tube it's
like no at least I could try to come up
with better ones
well tube beat a dead horse feed a Fed
horse you know you can't feed a fed of
wars bring home the bacon bring home the
bagels I like that one bring it on the
bagels for that one if you say that
people like really grab and bagels
tonight take the bull by the horns take
the flour by the thorns
can you imagine taking a flower by the
thorn your baby I bought you this rose
no I'm sorry that doesn't work at all on
any level okay Jesus Christ well this is
even the worst one this one was just
stupid and everyone's good filling them
this one this next one is just deep
right I mean I don't know this one so
this is a video they posted say
traditional masculinity is dead
the secret to male sexual stamina is
veggies the APA links talks of
traditional masculine linked to violence
which is also deadly to animals why men
should go vegan so here you go guys I
don't know why they picked all the
creepiest mother efforts to not to
reprise the role of hello is anybody
home the hell Twitter mm-hmm you know
find you different yeah you can just
find me at YouTube that's strange
yeah but this video actually made me
want to go stop being vegan I was like
[ __ ] who's gonna turn me into one of
these guys I need to eat meat right now
that's annoying
let me when you got it damn yeah I'm
looking maybe they did they have to
remove not on YouTube just take PETA
masculinity commercial yeah we watched
the last night what is this I mean it's
graphic but it's just well in the
commercial it's a bunch of creepy
weirdest looking dude you can imagine I
think Dan found it okay good it's
somebody recording off a screen though
should I not show this I mean it's
pretty explicit but it's just like it's
very explicit but it's just veggies
well here I'm not gonna feel I'll
describe it to you guys oh it's a shame
should I not show it to you uh is it too
risky it's just a carrot that they shave
him too big I mean the guy just nothing
that you're had done what do you think
you don't know I really know I mean this
one's been up for a minute it seems like
fine to me I don't know it's not really
nudity but these guys took like big-ass
squashes and carrots and taped it over
their pants and they're just so weird I
got to show it I feel like Facebook will
allow it this is let's just move on cuz
this is kind of but it's so dumb I I
don't know I mean Facebook is allowing
it so you YouTube has become so [ __ ]
lame I swear to God
YouTube has become so [ __ ] sensitive
it's more whitewash than television
by far like I was watching this guy
Oliver tree he is a really talented
musician he made this incredible music
video and it's totally fine
completely artistic and they
age-restricted it because there's one
scene where he gets decapitated it's not
violent it's very cartoonish and and
it's something you would see on MTV or
television no problem but YouTube has
become such [ __ ] [ __ ] you cannot
even curse you cannot I can't even show
it dude wearing a [ __ ] squash on his
dick because I'm afraid that the whole
episode is gonna get age-restricted
and they go oh well you can post it on
YouTube ya know I know it's gonna help
you but when a video gets age-restricted
nobody sees it it doesn't show up on the
home page isn't sort of suggested you
get like 90% less views that is not the
point of this it's so
[ __ ] [ __ ] we just got raised
restricted right there and like don't
put ads on him who gives a [ __ ] you know
especially when it's something artistic
like a music video yes Nicki Minaj shows
her [ __ ] giant [ __ ] on it and I'm
cursing now big to make a point
have you seen anaconda all the way up
her [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ] so
upsetting
why don't we describe it let's just show
it but I at this point see the problem
is that if I show it and gets
age-restricted
it really screws us so the whole app is
because our app because we have sponsors
that look at the view amounts and if we
end up getting 200,000 views instead of
like a million that really affects us I
think we can describe it you kind of got
to see it these dude they fastened giant
squash to their pants and they're
shaking their dick but they look insane
the music's insane it's really creepy
and disturbing yeah they're showing guys
then saying like they shaped they shaped
with vegetables you what looks like a
huge but they genitalia they made it
look really realistic like this guy has
a huge cucumber like 12 feet long and
then he has like like cilantro or
parsley that look like pubes and it
looks super realistic and then the next
guy but they look so creepy like maybe I
can just show you like here this guy's
face for justice still for him yeah all
right here let me see yeah their facial
expressions are like they're rapey
they're like there's like a huge carrot
that's up right like he's stiff and he
looks so creepy and then I Dan it just
says increase you're here this is sexual
stamina go Vegas face just like this guy
so he's got a huge carrot stiffy that's
like huge and I don't know I just don't
get the
like really this is how you think people
are gonna go vegan what are you insane
as a vegan now how did you feel when you
saw it I felt like I'm not I don't want
these people are fringed lunatics and I
won't want anything didn't do it them
and I want to eat meat I wanted to eat
meat after I watch this is that a spider
yeah did vegetables not increase your
veggie and sexual stamina it's not even
a thing like really you think like you
oh they're like we understand men they
want hard they want their dick harder
and they're gonna get that by going
vegan it's like really is that even a
thing is that good like looking at men
is like the lowest common denominator
they're like man just want their itch to
be harder yeah I'll do anything
God paired with the other ad that we
just talked about where they were
explicitly talking about toxic
masculinity and toxic behavior this does
this does kind of exhibit toxic
masculinity because there's dudes in the
club they're shaky
by the way like here's a shot of a guy
in the club with a bunch of girls here
I'll show you this still cuz it's on the
show his apparently too vulgar for
YouTube so so here he is with a girl
with the clubs and he's got a huge you
know squash and orange balls out but
here did you ask like he's in a public
setting and he's got his genitals out
that's toxic as it gets and they're
dancing like humping you know yeah super
sexual and look how the girls want it
they're like they're almost sending out
this message of oh why don't you just go
show your junk to anyone in public and
they'll want it PETA
guess who's problematic now all this
company is trying to be cool just calm
down just make a boring commercial
that's what we want seriously well don't
try to be a little ism yes God there's
nothing awful there's nothing worse than
like Gillette there's nothing worse than
like PR commercial advertisers trying to
be savvy you
like this company of ours look for you I
have been obsessed with the fire
festival documentary on Netflix though I
wash both of them but that I found out
that so [ __ ] Jerry was the company that
worked to promote manage the social
media yeah of the fire festival yeah and
then I found out the whole time was
watching the Netflix documentary I was
like wow these guys are really complicit
I'm surprised that this documentaries
not more critical of them because they
continued to promote them all the way
through the whole thing and they were
showing how the organizers were asking
them to delete comments and control the
narrative by deleting comments and
banning people and they're like so we
were deleting comments and I was like
you guys are really complicit in this so
it turns out that they are the ones that
produced that documentary the Netflix
documentary what that's how they had all
that insane footage the Netflix
production between them and vice the
Netflix documentary [ __ ] we're in really
disclosed that's weird
losed it they were filming and getting
all this incredible footage during this
fraud and then they produced the frickin
what that's so weird the documentary and
then I started going down this [ __ ]
Jerry rabbit hole they're just they're
just these they're like so Flo Antonio
but that's professional they just steal
[ __ ] from people and that people that
run that are such douches I watched this
clip of a news reporter being like so
tell me what do you guys do you just
create memes all day they're like here's
a picture make a make a meme of it and
they all try they're like me masters and
so they try writing a caption of like
this is me when my stepdad brings me
home from school too early and I was
like wow you are the biggest tool on the
planet Earth Wow so that's up anyway is
that what does that mean about the
documentary that's so
I feel like they needed to disclose that
yeah but speak and I noticed the Hulu
one that was not made by them yeah was
more critical of them saying that they
were being investigated by the FBI and
stuff like that
but no mention of it on Netflix pretty
Shady but a convenient and that's what
Dan told me so if I'm wrong about this
blamed in it they they definitely were
co-production company on the Netflix
documentary there's been a trending tag
[ __ ] [ __ ] Jerry what a flip that's right
what the flip and then I saw they're
just not it was great haven't watched it
I hate to say it but the Netflix one was
superior to the who the one but watch
both yeah watch both but oh my the
Netflix one was like one of my favorite
documentaries every it was such a thrill
ride it was just well they had more of
an inside scoop because they were
involved right I hate knowing that's the
other side of it yeah I hated knowing
that but that being said definitely
watch it because it's amazing and ja
Rule is such a clown this guy he was
like involved in everything oh yeah he
was a part-owner the only difference is
that this one guy Billy he was directly
lying to investors like he was saying
[ __ ] like like they had outside
investments of like you know tens of
millions of dollars when really they had
none saying that he owned a bunch of
stock in companies and had all these
liquid assets he didn't have any saying
that his previous company made like
millions of dollars when it made like
16,000 so he was falsifying documents
and lying to investors so he's
definitely his ass is fried I don't want
to ruin it cuz there's some really
amazing twists and turns in the Netflix
one but John there's these great scenes
with ja Rule were after it's a total
disaster and they get on a conference
call with ja Rule and all the senior
people in the company of the festival
and they're like dude we just committed
fraud they're all very uncomfortable
with everything that happened yeah and
they're all like toss what is going on
the call and ja rule is like no we
didn't commit fraud I would say if
anything it was false advertising I'm
like dude that's fraud
that's what fraud is and he's still
trying to make the whole thing work
after the fire festival was a complete
disaster
yeah and like people almost died I'm
surprised nobody is still trying to make
it work and on that call it's like
there's so many smart people on this
call right now it's like come on you
guys can figure it out like I'm not one
of the smart people on the call but
there's so many smart people on this
call right now it's like how do you
figure out that you defrauded like 50
million bucks figure this out guy and
then Billy the organizer after the flop
there was an interview of him he's like
well obviously uh version one didn't
work out we are refunding everyone and
giving them discounts to version two
which will be next year I love it the
scam never stops love it super
entertaining watch the damn thing let's
move on and then there was that RKO
documentary oh my goodness the r.kelly
one that's also a Netflix right no was
it HBO
lifetime lifetime oh so it's on TV thank
you jack so lifetimes all over it lately
they did the Scientology stuff too
didn't they or was that a knee I don't
there's too many networks I'm so sick of
cable such a scam I pay like $120 a
month and I feel like I'm watching
commercials half of the time yeah
at any rate the arc le document was
really disturbing really acid we talked
here about that one article I was having
a yeah and basically it just confirms
everything and more he makes all of his
girls call him daddy
he has like an initiation process where
he breaks them in slowly to the point
where he'll basically locks them in
their bedrooms permission to go to pee
to eat yeah move to get out of the room
yeah um daddy or he beats them up they
takes away their phone
I called her friendly anymore so it's a
cult well it's more like it's more like
torture than a cult because they all
don't want to be there they're just
afraid to leave same with a lot of cults
well I feel like was theirs brainwashed
to thinking they want to be there but I
think it's the same with them because
like when BuzzFeed that article came out
they recorded an interview with one of
the girls and she was like I'm not being
held
well at any blurred line yes or Capel at
any rate it's really disturbing highly
recommend watching it that dudes a creep
to the max I mean listen guys it's
public knowledge that he was boning alia
what's her name yeah earlier yeah when
she was like 14 or something 15 years
old age ain't nothing but a number rest
in peace
yeah r.i.p alia r.i.p yep
yeah man it's crazy it's so crazy and
then we go to the absurd on another end
Kevin Hart was set to host the Oscars
and then of course the Twitter warriors
of the world
pull ten-year-old tweets and then caused
outrage that forces him to step down now
then before 10 but but yeah well here
let me sum it says the year here on
these years is from they were quite old
of course he cut out the year can you
guys find out what your this tweet is
from um yeah I'm Lea various but and
then meanwhile look at this smug look at
this smug let me show you this smug
guy's face okay okay look at that yep
got him I'll never get the house to
Oscars so you will
I never got the host of Oscars and I
never made a gay joke in my life it's
like a lot of them were 2011 ish so yeah
I mean like eight years okay okay so
here he goes
Benjamin says and Oscar for most
homophobic host ever goes to so here's
the here's a quote of the tweet or I
guess now there's a quote from one of
his movies from 2010 which is nine years
ago one of my biggest fears is my son
growing up and being gay that's a fear
keep in mind I'm not homophobic be happy
do whatever you want to do but me as a
heterosexual male if I can prevent my
son from being gay I will he said during
his 2010 movie seriously funny before
going into a skit about times when
Hendrix may have exemplified homosexual
tendencies to which he would response
I'm doing my best Kevin Hart stop that's
gay from 2010 but anyone was following
Kevin Hart these days this is nothing
you wouldn't hear from him today it's
been a while people nine years a lot has
changed do you know how much of a person
you change in nine years
well how much the wasn't acceptable to
say and not yeah you know also making
gay jokes was like everyone was always
making gay jokes it was just I don't
know it's just that thing at that time
you can find probably a lot of people
you I like how they go back and judge
people by the standards of today based
on things they said ten years ago
like it doesn't work that way and people
grow up in certain environments where I
don't know where I grew up it was kind
of like not acceptable to be gay and
yeah you know you kind of grow up like
that but then you change right and he
changed he's not like that today yeah
but I mean really and frankly he what he
said was I mean in all and all fairness
not really even even if he said that
today it's tasteless but Mike
that's not hard to translate it's out of
context
yeah like in our lawsuit it was so funny
they would write exactly what we said
and analyze it and when you just read it
versus like seeing it with facial
expressions and whatever so much is lost
and then you just judge based on a few
words I haven't seen this this scene but
as a parent think about it like that as
a parent you know being gay is harder
than being straight because you have to
deal with more challenges in your life
because I think probably if you're gay
there's more challenges one you're not
you're not considered normal by a lot of
people so you have to adjust to not
being like most of the people around you
okay have a hard time it's more
challenging let's say that I think
that's a fair thing to say so you could
even turbit as him saying look I don't
want my son to go through I'm more
challenging childhood right I mean it
doesn't matter I'm not trying to say
that what he said here is fine yeah
doesn't matter so he goes I wonder when
Kevin Hart is gonna start deleting all
of his old tweets okay did he erase
anything I like how he's like making it
sound like he is erasing them so here he
shows more these ones are from 2011 he
lifts my son comes home and tries to
play with my daughter's dollhouse I'm
going to break it over his head and say
and my voice stop that's gay 2010 you
know he just did a Twitter search for
gay Kevin Hart
why does Damien DW profile pic look like
a gay billboard for AIDS boom I'm on
fire tonight I don't know any of those
tweets are yeah I was wondering why it's
written like a middle schooler
yeah it's pretty bad but where was he in
his career in 2010 I was like a
different world where people even on
Twitter in 2010 was was he Twitter was
it was just starting to get big around
then I think like I wonder how many
likes these tweets have probably like
less than a hundred
why does Wayne to15 have so many
pictures of me and his phone what are
you some type of fat [ __ ] that takes pics
of small black men all day 2009 again
like that
is trying to make a joke clearly
tasteless today yeah but I think
obviously it was a lot more acceptable
to say that [ __ ] back then yeah yeah my
thing is to his this guy that called him
out you know in the Oscar for most
homophobic host ever goes to dude like
[ __ ] Bob Hope use he hosts the Oscars
every year it's like all of his just
same guys who made those Folgers
commercials right exactly it was like
yeah not so much
yeah but again also he's he's apologized
for this stuff already before Yeah right
that was the weird thing is this this
controversy already happened right like
five years ago there was kind of like a
big brought up about me addressed it
apologized and then just like well okay
it's like you said it's been a decade I
mean is he just not supposed to work for
the rest of his life because of this but
again it's like dude he didn't kill
anybody he just made some tasteless
jokes ten years ago he didn't do
anything
do you are you not promoting like change
for the better like what if someone did
think that and then they understood they
were stupid to think that and they
changed because culture changed and they
understand now that it's not what people
used to think I mean that's true in my
case
I've gone back and watched some of the
old videos I used to make like back in
Israel like before people used to watch
her videos and some of the stuff I was
saying was outraged on me it was so
vulgar and um see I know of myself that
there was no hate or malice behind it
but I was so vulgar and so insensitive
with the way I talked you know I made
Sean me it maybe it made me really feel
awful about myself imagine if someone
took one of those and just would you
transcribe what do you what is the word
for it when you write the
right into tricks yeah yeah yeah
transcribed it and post it on whatever
yeah just the text yeah of course like
even way works well and also and their
intention is to make it look worse
so they frame it in whatever way makes
it look the worst for you mm-hmm but
again the most valuable change as well
and all these offensive things he
couldn't find anything recent it's like
bro this is all [ __ ] you're a wooden
eight nine ten years ago that he's
already talked about if you're following
I following today it's all about like
positivity and he's just having a good
time with his kids family stuff it was
working hard is like you would never
find any of this stuff today
yeah so his point was that he's like
dude I've already talked about this this
happened so long ago I'm not gonna
apologize every time this comes up it's
like and and that's a totally fair point
and I think he's right that people need
to stop pandering to these people
because this is not progress it really
is not progress and so the debate
continues man this guy's such a douche
like I think to this day there's no new
host announced it's such a Plaza to it
because it's just like way too much of a
spotlight I guess it's just such false
righteousness it's like this guy thinks
he's doing something righteous and it's
just it's so the opposite you know I
mean look how we write instead of
encouraging people to change you know
yeah maybe maybe it was a little and I
wrote about why Kevin Hart's homophobia
isn't welcome at next year's Oscars what
how could the Academy I hire this
homophobic [ __ ]
do we really set the bar at homophobic
that low like pick on people who are
today homophobe right that's right
because that would be I think we all
need to accept the fact that
people grow and change and in 9 years is
like a lifetime of development I mean
like the videos that I used to make some
of them I don't know if you guys will
watch them and have the same reaction as
me but when I saw them I was like oh my
god I was so embarrassed by that person
so doesn't represent Who I am or what I
would say today and how I feel
mousse I was deeply horrified and
embarrassed of this stuff and I wouldn't
want to be judged by that because we all
human beings grow and develop five years
is enough let alone ten um let's let's
look at what people are now you know
let's look at who people have become how
far back do you go 10 15 20 years it's
like ask your grandma about [ __ ] she was
saying when she was 18 grandma you wants
uh it says here grandma that you once
called a black person hey Negro when you
are 18 and well grandma I'm just I'm
gonna divorce you Negros not that bad
either Wednesday I don't know
well it's funny the whole I don't even
go there yeah you either had a panic
attack when I said Negro I don't think
I've had think I can I didn't say it his
grandma did that guy's grandma's a
frickin racist man Benjamin Lee those
people's grandparents are raised exactly
thank you Dan
that's progress not this but anyway the
story develops I've labored this long
enough moving on so Kevin Hart goes on
Ellen where's my mouse and and Ellen
gives him hit her support and and she's
gay she's a gay woman obviously too so
he stepped down from hosting right it
wasn't that they fired him Ellen oh they
did fire him saying that he needed to
apologize okay and he was like you know
what he was like I'm over it
no desire to host the show and also
after these mother effing web sites that
she contact
did the cap they pop up like 20 videos
so he was just over it he's like you
know what I don't want to do this
mm-hm and good for him here's the video
people were super angry at Alan for
supporting him like here's one tweet it
says this is truly a misstep for you
Alan he might be your friend and maybe
that's clouding your judgment but he's
not sorry and hasn't apologized even
here they say the only thing Kevin Hart
proved by going on was that he's a
terrible actor was zero general and
remorse remorse he did not do anything
I thought what a judge say it is like a
serial killer there's clearly no remorse
in your eyes clearly there's no remorse
for the tweets you made 10 years ago up
saying you hope your son's not gay in my
there's so many angry Ellen can't
forgive someone on behalf of the
community Lowell that's not how this
works
I think she gave Kevin a pass instead of
having an actual productive conversation
in my Yeti ed yeah so let's watch the
clip where's the clip
um oh my god I hate this our frickin
website here it is um bear with me guys
dead air dead air here we go why I can't
click any Twitter videos dear what is
happening today
so it is Twitter huh Twitter well that's
new mm-hmm can you find it on YouTube
yeah I got you alright man what the half
uh let's see here so as of now there is
no host to the Oscars making it possibly
the first Oscars since 1989 to have no
host and said it may just be a series of
celebrities introducing various
categories that sounds thrilling
enjoy the awful ratings I'm sure
everyone wants to watch that he had said
specifically that he did not want to be
a distraction and so three days after
the announcement he stepped down for his
previous tweets we've got the video
thank you I saw on YouTube I hosted the
Oscars we went to dinner and we talked
about you hosting always wanted to host
the Oscars I said you should host the
Oscars then you get asked to I mean it
must have been amazing when they asked
you to host this year I'm real you know
there's there's a lot of goals that I
have on my board I got a vision board
and on that vision board there's so many
things that I want to do - I'll check
off as they get done and Oscars was up
there Oscars was one of the highest of
high simply because there hasn't been a
lot of african-american comedians that
have been able to do it I would have
been the fourth so to get the moment
celebrate the moment oh my god I can't
believe it's happening and then the next
morning after a day full of
congratulations and celebrations I'm hit
with the non slack
on social media of my past coming back
up again literally the next morning
mm-hmm
not even a full 24 hours to glow and the
glory of Kevin Hart is hosting this
year's Oscars and when it happened you
know my first my first thought is I'm
gonna ignore it I'm gonna ignore it
because it's ten years old
this is stuff I've addressed I've I've
talked about this this isn't new I've
addressed it I've apologized for it I'm
not gonna pay it any mind cuz you feed
on that stuff you only add more fuel to
the fire
right ha I'm not gonna do I'm gonna
leave it alone
now the day goes by the fuel is now is
growing this this fire is angry it's all
over the place now the headlines are
starting to change the headlines are
Kevin Hart refuses to apologize for
homophobic tweets from the pass the word
again was left out everybody took those
headlines and started to run with it so
now the slander on my name is all
homophobia now I'm a little upset I'm
gonna upset because I Know Who I am
I don't have a homophobic bone in my
body I know that arrested I know that
I've apologized I know that within my
apologies I've taken 10 years to put my
apology to work I yet to go back to that
version of the amateur comedian that
once was I've moved on I'm a grown man
I'm cultured I'm manufactured I'm I'm a
guy that understands now I look at life
through a different lens and because of
that I live it a different way so now
I'm kind of upset because these 10 years
are just being ignored they're being
brush pets nobody is saying guys this is
this is ten years no headlines are
saying ten years ago he apologized
nobody's finding the apologies nobody's
finding the footage from where I had to
address it I had to address it when I
did get heart promo with Will Ferrell
because of my joke that I had about my
son I had to address those tweets in
2012 and a very very heavy heavy junket
where I was asked questions and ask
questions about homophobia based on
those tweets and I had to address it and
apologize and say I understand what
those words doing how they hurt I
understand why people would be upset
which is why I made the choice to not
use them anymore
I don't joke like that anymore because
that was wrong that was a guy that was
just looking for less and I was stupid I
don't do that anymore so to be put in a
position where I was given ultimatum I
was given an ultimatum
Kevin apologize or we're gonna have to
find another house ultimatum this is now
it's now becoming like a Clow what was
once the brightest star and brightest
light ever just got rode dark the Oscars
is no longer about Kevin Hart stepping
on that stage and taking a intense night
where people are so uptight and making
it loose and fun that's my reason for
doing it I'm gonna bring fun to the
Oscars I'm gonna make the Oscars fun now
all of a sudden he's right he's right
how are you gonna make sure cuz the
conversations about Oscars yeah
conversations about Kevin Hart's sweets
from 10 years ago and homophobia mm-hmm
I don't want to step on that stage and
make that night about me and my past
when you got people that have worked
hard to step on that stage for the first
time and receive an award I'm now taking
away from all those moments because the
night is it's focused on something else
now that's how I see it because that
would have been an apologize again while
stepping down once again I'm sorry if
these words hurt I'm sorry but either my
apology is accepted
or it isn't either I can move forward or
I can but you can't grow as a person
without mistakes you don't know what
perfection is unless you've experienced
imperfection
so I don't know the perfect individual
that society is now looking for thank
you
it's not me well it's David I'll be the
first to say it I'm open book there is
no perfect bone in my body I have made
several mistakes
several embrace them I'm alone on a day
because of in this case I just said I'm
going to walk away because I felt like
there was a conversation I was just
going to continue and continue and
continue yeah
I will much rather say I'm sorry again
and walk away because I'm I'm I want to
be done with the conversation I don't
want to have to have this conversation
anymore because I Know Who I am I'm not
that guy I know you're not that guy
because I nose nose mom so I'm gonna
take a break because I have thoughts but
I want that to stay exactly as it is so
I'll take a break and I'll give you my
thoughts because I I think that the
night I was not wonderfully stated yeah
I actually have after listening to that
I agree with him that he made the right
choice yeah you know we yes yes we are
all flawed who are these perfect people
that society you're looking for this guy
that started this whole thing like it's
like he's saying it was just immature
trying to get a laugh yeah we've all
been there yeah and you grow you
understand that was wrong you don't do
it again again this guy Benjamin Lee
like you that perfect individual that
ten years ago never said anything
offensive ten years ago it's just so
stupid but Danny to make matters worse
Ellen gets a ton of [ __ ] like I was
reading just simply for having him on
and saying that she doesn't think he's
homophobic yeah she vouches for him that
she called the Academy and said that she
thinks that he should host and all of
this and so this guy says unfortunately
mrs. Ellen this is not your fight the
harm is the harm is done and this man
hasn't learned why are you saying that
he hasn't learned that's what I wonder I
farm is done
I saw his comedy specials I follow you
on Instagram all that stuff why are you
saying
that he hasn't changed he's nothing also
she's a gay woman what do you mean it's
not her fight who's hosted the Oscars
yeah I find it might be her opinion
matters she's very if she's not
qualified to speak on it then who is
right you sorry Ellen
this isn't your fight okay it really is
she goes he goes the harm is done it's
like he did not kill anybody he's
worried about his pockets not the
community he has harmed listen to you
but he declined the job if he's worried
about his pocket these people are not
progress they are the opposite I hate it
anyway
that's that speaking of Ellen Ellen's
kind of on fire lately
Sandra you know Sandra Bullock
I call her Sandra bollocks who wears my
rimshot Sandra bollocks anyone so Sandra
Bullock's developed a facial treatment
did we talk about this she didn't
develop it yeah it's hers hers and this
other hey Trebek insane I thought she
was just getting the treatment no no
it's her as she's and she's invested in
this yeah just particulate Oh Sandra
Bullock and Kate Beckinsale swear by it
Oh maybe I'm wrong where am I yeah I
think there's no advocates I don't think
well I was thinking who would go on
record and talk about this even if you
did like it so there's a $650 it's
called penis facial now the facial penis
facials that I know of are very
different than than the ones that she
describes in fact
that's true I hear that well but so what
they do is and this is so strange you
guys and I apologize they well here I
have a picture let me show you its
liquefied they take baby foreskin Korean
before and a specifically Korean baby
foreskin now apparently the Koreans have
got some extra spicy foreskin here's the
procedure and they literally make baby
foreskin deposits deep within your
facial tissue and they call it if to
make matters worse the penis facial we
should say it's cloned baby foreskin
they at least had only the raw stuff cut
fresh from the vine well the originally
it was damn well I mean yeah it started
somewhere
it changed started somewhere right it's
good to say that it's cloned well can I
take all it like the stem cell treatment
or something why the penis facial are
you [ __ ] mental
like seriously Oh whose penis a baby's
Korean baby
well anyway Sandra bollocks comes on
Ellen and Alan kind of she she uh she
handles it very well she found of
Lampoon's it which I'm happy to see a in
which horses through micro needling it's
like a little roller with these some of
you I'm gonna think many of you know it
pushes through the skin and ruptures of
collagen and then boost it you look like
a burn victim for a day but then it's it
but then it pushes what are you pushing
into the skin Sarah Sarah said
Carrie what are you pushing into the
skin
well you push in whatever the facialist
would like to insert into your pores but
what is it
it is extraction from a piece of skin
that came from a young person is this
the is this the Hollywood elite satanic
cult we've been hearing about from a
young person holy god it's like she got
caught red-handed extract its foreskin
from a Korean baby funny I find it
deeply disturbing and so I really have
to actually you know what I've been I
gotta say I kind of say don't say it
don't say it no I'm just gonna say I
think I like Ellen she has her moments I
don't like her dancing when I read that
time she shamed the fan for stealing him
yeah I'm saying she but she like many
people's has her good and bad moments
but I think on the whole she's been
doing some good stuff lately you know
she put her neck out there for Kevin
good role today and she's calling out
these peaceful penis facials where she
sees them I like her now next month who
knows it's not like I'm lying there with
little pieces all over my face it thinks
of collecting it and having it for will
do something with this
and so so we call it like well I call it
the penis facial and I think I think
when you see how good it is to your face
you too will run to your local facialist
and say put giving me the penis Wow Wow
sorry thank you for a minute yeah this I
find that all very strange
we should both get it whoo
perfect I'm a freak Amish Sandra
bollocks how old is she
let's see let's make a distinction is it
working for or not Sandra bollocks
that's her name by the way from now you
think she looks freaky looks good well
let's see how old is she
she is uh Wow she's 90 she's 54
see I mean she's got a nose job that I
don't like I don't like plastic surgery
it's very apparent looks like she's had
a lot of work done for probably your
moneymaker and for my and I bet you she
makes an awful pot of coffee
[Music]
um yeah but after she gives it to us
really yeah give her a penis facials
yeah that's all I got a penis facial for
you right here baby girl
you don't gotta spend $650 well there's
a lot more to go to but we've already
been going nice and juicing them long
we've got a great episode we cover a lot
of topics I'll save these for the next
time we've got a lot of other topics I
want to talk about here but um if you
want for your birthday we could both go
get a penis special I owe ya Dan good
call okay yeah sure let's do that but we
can do that at home what there was one
thing I wanted to talk about before we
left was we had one fan submission that
I wanted to bring up vapenation an
extreme place it almost rhymes nation
extreme places that should be a thing
yeah we need like a a we need some kind
of slick
little animation hey Ethan and Neela
I've been following you guys for many
years and I've always thought of myself
as one of your biggest fans I know
that's a bold statement to make so let
me rephrase that I'm your biggest fan in
the world and I mean that in a literal
sense at an altitude of 19,000 for 341
feet I'm probably the highest envy yeah
I think he means VN ace representor in
the world podcast number 99 and 100 kept
me company while climbing the last 8
hour long stage in the top of
Kilimanjaro Africa's highest mountain
all in all I just want to say thank you
for the amazing work and congratulations
on the start of season 2 this comes from
[Music]
Momiji so Mitchie hereby claims himself
to be the biggest fan at the summit of
Kilimanjaro that's technically the
highest AJ fan high a lot of her fans
would probably contend that they are the
highest bid at 19,000 341 feet it was
listening to the podcast while climbing
I guess what I want to say in honor of
him is that if you have other babe
nations and extreme locations yeah I
would love to see it that's really cool
send your submissions and anything else
all other submissions do podcast at h3h3
productions comm so shout out to this to
this Papa bluster ichi and we should say
within reason don't hurt yourself please
please don't mean god thank you Dan
if if it looks dangerous I may not don't
show it yeah we're here for the goofs
Yeah right now the cringe God is doing
something dangerous I'm yeah sorry
cringe god it's not happening
well that's about wraps it up Opie guys
had a beautiful week I hope you have a
terrific week end this is the new time
we're thinking about doing the Mew the
timing is great again
you know around it just consumes our
whole day when we do it and but beyond
that I kept around that time and I get
so tired I just want to take a nap at 3
o'clock would you only usually start so
I like this you know I like that I like
that I really like so I hope that my
opinions were well I know my opinions
were correct as they always are this is
the correct opinion zone and I hope that
if you disagree you can go educate
yourself and figure out rewatch this
listen closer and you'll find that my
opinions are and will always be correct
so thank you everyone for watching have
a terrific weekend we love you we
appreciate you and remember to throw out
your Gillett remember to throw your
Gillette razors in your toilet and don't
feed a fat horse you know don't feed a
Fed horse with our dumb do two birds
with us cone don't ya feed two birds
whisk with once ago I hope you have a
real productive weekend and feed two
birds with one scone everyone all right
well I'm gonna go give myself a penis
facial now hello I hope you all the very
best and also hoping this podcast
doesn't get D it doesn't get
age-restricted for simply mentioning
this PETA commercial where dudes have
giant cucumbers or penises that about
wraps are up a how about next week
watching what is next week then Chris
D'Elia is coming up great welcome back
for Stallion next Friday very much
looking forward to that super funny
talented comedian always have a great
time with them mm-hmm looking forward to
that so do not miss it for the world
we'll see you then guys thanks for
watching Dada